okay welcome everyone today we're
looking at TLC 90-day fiance
this is the show about meeting a wife in
90 days I think I never watched it we
have here edy who's met a wife online
can relate of course 100% and he's about
to find if this is the love of his life
sounds like a massive simpie if you ask
me cringe all right let's see what EDD
is all about in a few days I'm getting
ready to get on a plane and go meet rose
the love of my life for the lovers top
his life now why you see grabbing a
spatula and some mayo to ring and I plan
to ask rose to marry me oh my god this
is a joyous joyous occasion you should
always what is it with Americans is just
getting married I don't know where met
you once married we married now married
gang no oh well since I met Rose I I
want to look young for her other lip is
that working out for you you're putting
mayo in your hair look at that look at
that burn I mean how can you not fall
for the sex spot so I have been dyeing
my hair and you're being dyeing your
hair with mayonnaise it irritates my
scalp so I found out that mayonnaise
makes it smoother and less dry oh I'm so
reposed why would you do that surely
there's some shampoo that you can use
for dry scalps Mayo I thought the point
of these was that the guy is rich and he
meets the girl abroad that wants a green
card what the hell is this I'm
self-conscious of my physical appearance
because Rose mayonnaise isn't going to
fix that surely there's younger than me
I smell like
an egg salad sandwich but really I want
to feel younger smells like an egg
sandwich yeah that'll do the trick
you look so young
is that egg I just want to look young
for Rose mm-hmm I bet you he I bet you
he you know this is not about the hair
come on
so ed is preparing to meet its fee
honestly he's gonna fly over so he's
packing his bag he's talking to his
friend or whatever I don't know who this
is all this a giant a giant pack of mini
pops when you go abroad you just can't
leave without it I have stuff for their
son Prince oh it's for the son Ferrum
bringing toys how old is he
Prince is four okay 110 years maybe 64
you'd be 14 brother house yet and what's
the plan they're like well when I start
drooling he's gonna give me a paper
towel like seriously like does she want
more kids did she tell you that or not
well shorty wants another child she
wants a girl and I he's like don't do it
mate don't know it I don't want to tell
her this but I want to get like nipped
okay wait so him this is a recipe for
disaster the fact that he's lying about
yeah you know what he's doing it right
lie a lie about everything I think this
is his only chance to be honest I have
been keeping a few things from Rose a
few things
it's 411 not that there's anything wrong
we're being short I just can't relate to
it what does that in centimeter oh my
god you can't even ride roller coasters
with that this is about to get
interesting
so he's lied about his landing not five
- he said it was five - what is five -
okay I mean that's still
there's another thing and that is I
don't want any more kids I want to get a
vasectomy but I don't want to tell her
I'm at a place in my life or I've raised
my daughter oh my what how how does it
go from this to this oh my god what in
the world I gotta read the comments the
neck doesn't bother me the fact is
dating someone younger than his brother
I'm just saying his daughter is hella
gorgeous she must take her looks from
her mom DNA be like I don't want this
I'll go with it how does that work I
don't know how to tell her I don't want
to break her heart tell her you need to
tell us you know that's gotta be fair so
yeah I all right so it's time for them
to meet the joyous occasion of their
reunion for the first time what the hell
oh my god what in the world was that
sound so beautiful all right how long
until that she comments about that
length or the height I mean
[Music]
I'm beyond beyond elated I'm so happy
right now
I'm so very happy to see you you
promised I'd say they've invaded McNair
yes I am too
I couldn't find you because why
Travie Oh traffic them huh you know I
will imagine there's some gold digger or
something like that or two just like
they're usually very intolerable to say
the least but she seems okay it was just
like an out-of-body experience for me
because from three months I faced I'm
sure she wishes so as well I'm sorry her
and now I'm standing in front of her and
I really want to kiss Rose I really do
oh here comes Erica
am i what you expected do you like I
mean you did lie I told you I was the
same height maybe I would have a chance
I see on first in person but sure yeah
they're the same
oh this is for shedding fur
later tonight do you find me attractive
always well you are sorry for me I would
settle for okay
I would settle for okay I would do that
only be your man yeah your man
a Michael I'm her king she's my queen oh
my god I just want to look at you sweet
all right so it's going well how about
that maybe there's gonna be the star
that's full of sweet I'm surprised it in
without a yo-yo or anything I mean
classic amateur mistake right there he
could have shown him at least some moves
alright next clip is a rose scamming big
Edie
all right about to get juicy huh so
they're in Manila I think I saw it
before no you hate it come on Rose
doesn't even have a jammas made me feel
really sad so what why this is so sad
this is a great tragedy she's been
through a lot guys the first thing I'm
gonna do is get her pajamas
[Music]
you go from my wallet I want to see how
much this dude look at this sweat he's
working at what is happening here how
long did he shoot this oh my god this is
destroying him she took my money
my ten pesos how much is that oh wow
ya know understandably he should be
upset I'm just in a swarm of hot sweaty
people right now yeah they're sweaty you
on me over a hundred degrees know what
else my ass off right now
Oh Mike hey I was iam and address with
virus alright I like this shirt okay
hold on hold on I'm not comfortable with
Rose grabbing my money because that's
not what you do it seems like she's
literally just trying to help him he
doesn't know the currency obviously how
can she do it she wants to scam II think
it's borderline you know inappropriate
and I already have questions about her
sister yes oh you know she asked me for
money
her sister texted me the other night she
basically said you know I need help my
store is gonna close and she's asking me
for money
Oh how much does she want ten pesos
sorry cannot happen that this could just
be a scam but I don't know if Rose is in
on it or not this guy oh my god
why is he so paranoid you're the one
that lies about everything
Edie asked Rose to take an STD tatty
sighs cries I know you're tired of me
asking about your past and I don't want
to do that anymore I want to put it
behind us but first you need to take an
STD test so there's a test that you can
take so there's this thing it's amazing
all right you probably don't know what
it is but like you just go in and it's
[ __ ] you just need to do you do it it's
like you need to do it what about you
know STD which is I think it's a blood
test and they well for someone that
doesn't want to have kids huh and you
haven't got snipped yet why don't you
just use a condom for now just test to
see oh my god if you have like sexually
transmitted disease so that so I was
asking if you're willing to take that
test I will never ask you again and
another question about your past
[Music]
I finally understand what he said about
sto she's 23
[Music]
oh really
the guy's a compulsive liar why would he
trust someone else lies about his height
I don't know what else probably nicer by
not wanting kids not that fundamental
anyway you give an ugly guy a chance and
he thinks he's taking negative comments
the naked Dave garbage
wait he's forcing her to get an STD test
when he was what who cheated on his my
weight he cheated the audacity I have a
bad feeling about this relationship guys
I don't know I don't know where I got it
from that I don't have I don't know if
it's gonna work out I'm feeling like
it's over
Jesus well I'm not ready to get good
yeah you can go home fine then I decided
to text her into garlic anime wife I
don't know of respect and ask her to
meet me at a cafe nearby strangely it
isn't his physical appearance that makes
him such a deeply Duke Leto as little
troll but its attitude the YouTube
comments
has no shell my god there we go
they made up thank you for coming I
wanted to tell you face-to-face that I'm
sorry
and that I trust you now she's gonna get
an STD test sooner I promise you I
promise you Wendy
really you understand what my point last
night
yes you don't need to subtitle her I
understand what she's saying
that does not help guide lies about
everything
just entrust the woman all right so now
they're gonna go to her home that should
be interesting
so they made up how great we get to
follow everybody Sean vibes from the you
brulee video guys you will not believe
he's 56 but it's still age like a boy
God you have no right to say you should
you put mayonnaise in your hair you are
not allowed to say what's gross or not
about all the people okay those are the
rules
those are the rules god damn it's gross
hates brothers so it's soft your legs
will be soft like my skin and then you
shove a on it's super soft
come on either you kissing sounds I love
you there grunts dude look at that yeah
I love you yeah yeah that's love right
there yeah yeah I see what I like Oh
trust me trust me you do not want to see
him wear that I be it that's it it's
gonna look like a penis trust me it
ain't gonna be good he looks like their
librarian from Monster saying see I feel
like I've seen him before
okay all right okay all right that's a
little harsh do you guys think there's a
neck reveal coming up oh wow they jump
right to it with a family big edge
showers with rose dad as you do when I
meet the dad the first time come on bro
you're pushing right sure okay
it's normal to my family need it wash
together our clothes and our thumb with
each other no I don't want to see this
he's like where's the mayor come on whip
it out she just enjoys terrorizing him
at this point this has to be the
weirdest experience of my life bro ain't
nothing wrong [ __ ] ain't nothing wrong
showering with your fiance's dad ain't
nothing wrong - what do you think why do
you think she's with yo she's poor
[Music]
there's chickens but there no mayo what
the bleep dude don't drop the soap what
a with the dad
who that could have been awkward is that
a chicken is that a chicken oh my god
Rose what is that it's a chicken mouse
that's a mouse or a rat what I feel that
I'm going to make Hotel Reservations as
soon as possible of course you are
yeah but he called first I want to ask
her father if it's okay out of respect
because I'm a father and I would expect
the same but I'm not sure how he's
feeling about me what if he says no
I'm pretty sure he'll be happy to have
you out of the house I excited Navona
marzetta need young Bobby and Ito it's
excited to show its pig farm I have a
feeling Edison excited to see the pig
farm vision and avocados puja that is
not impressed he's gonna feed them oh my
god oh my god how do you mess up so bad
so Rose where does your dad live yeah
here inside oh my god big this is pretty
humbling to see it all it's all starting
to make sense a lot of the pieces are
falling together
is he like living here yeah bad open and
Etowah yes yes these are my father
passed on yeah this is fun no tell me I
had a lot of fun at the Monday show yeah
this was good oh my god so there's
something that I wanted to ask you last
night I had a hard time sleeping because
it was so hot so I wanted to take a
vacation for a couple days with Rose if
you're okay with that though you know
think of me I feel my dad is always
protected in me so I feel nervous
because I don't I have no idea if he
said yes or no
oh well I gotta know City Hall
well how did you so much okay we'll see
you again soon amazing
alright so that's all we know about big
end so far that's where his saga ends
abruptly maybe when's more content comes
out I'll do another follow-up on this if
you enjoyed this video
gently hit the like button that's all
you gotta do smash like if you but smash
like if your floor gang ceiling gang
cringe and I'll see you guys tomorrow
subscribe 30% aren't subscribe
[Music]
I wanna have the best of the PP to crush
the rest and get a piece Jennifer got me
sleepy Mary Stefano found on Shannon
sponsee Edgar Maya Tuskegee sword mill 3
crushing boiling what you're calling
singing fix the lid some across the
world nothing from dusk till dawn and I
borrow your power cord my phone is down
you know Sarah's but I gotta come at
birch Cobre comma holy Claudia Rudy roll
the king clean cheap or estoppel it's
polish bowling what you're calling
pinging pixely no one is stronger than
me how many pictures GU from breath down
to crush your polish this is my song as
you notice
will soon be gosh push to arcpad Nasser
Abdul Roxie men 14 Sally got so few
[Applause]
picture links the greatest game of all
time
download it now before to it that's
right this whole song is actually a
commercial I'm spoiling while it's
boiling what you call a king in I'm
falling falling spoiling weren't you
calling dinging house boys boys boiling
what you calling
big Serling's
[Music]